depuis sa publication partiel en
Allemagne il y a un peu plus de 60 ans
l'homme sans qualité de l'Autrichien
Robert Musil est un livre qui fait peur
je m'en presse de préciser que cette
crainte est en tout point fondée il faut
en convenir d'emblé près de 2000 page
d'une intrigue Toufu à la fois familiale
et historique que le seuil réédite en
deux volumes traduits par Philippe
jacoté dans sa collection de poche
roman Musil qui n' quitte à Klagenfurt
en 1880 songea successivement à devenir
officier ingénieur et philosophe un
premier roman les désarrois de l'élève
turles le fait remarquer en 1906 le
cinéast allemand folkchlendorf en a tiré
un film bien connu Musil vit à Berlin
comparaissent les deux premières époques
de l'homme sans qualité Hitler arrive au
pouvoir l'écrivain s'exile à Genève où
il meurt sans pouvoir terminer son
maître livre c'est l'histoire d'Ulric
mêlée à la tempétueuse destinée de
l'autriche- Hongrie d'un François Joseph
en fin de règne impérial et royale la
double monarchie charit les espérances
et les contradictions du siècle naissant
ulrc tout d'intelligence hésite devant
l'action il retrouve son double parfait
en la personne de sa sœur Agathe
monument du siècle l'homme en qualité
revê une ampleur vertigineuse qui
rappellera au lecteurs français à la
fois Gide Freud et Martin
[Musique]
Dugard